hello and welcome to this session on sql
server tutorial
today we are going to talk about
sql server what benefit it provides
and some queries and some
sql syntaxes which will help you
understand how to use sql queries
now let's see what's in it for us today
we will discuss what is sql server
the usage of sql server
different sql server editions and the
differences between them
and then what are the advantages of sql
server instances
and after that i'll show you execution
of some queries
some insert statements on the sql server
instance which i have installed
now what is sql server in any
application development today in any
computer application which we develop
database sql server plays a very
important and pivotal role
sql servers are used for persistence of
information
in your database which can be retrieved
mined
data mined or you can query it at a
later point of time
the benefit of having any sql server is
that data
is persisted in a structured
efficient
manner so that it can be retrieved later
quickly and meaningfully
so sql server is a relational database
management system in which you can
create tables two-dimensional tables
and connect them using referential
integrity like primary key foreign key
and other kind of integrity constraints
you can maintain in this relational
database
sql server is developed and marketed by
microsoft so this is a microsoft product
but it is compatible with all the
technologies which you want which you
might be using or you might want to use
like node.js java etc where you want to
connect your middleware
application server with microsoft sql
server
now what is the usage of sql server
apart from the
definition which i just shared with you
for maintaining and building databases
persistent databases there are other
usages also which i'll explain you
now the first one is sql server analysis
service which is used to analyze data
now the sql server analysis service or
ssas is a multi-dimensional analysis
tool
that features online analytical
processing provide powerful data mining
capabilities and deeper dimensions to
business information within a relational
database
multi-dimensional analysis is an online
analytical processing technique olap
technique
that produces the ability to analyze
large quantities of data by storing data
in access and cells instead of
traditional
relational two-dimensional view in rows
and columns
ssas places predictive analytic
capabilities in the hands of information
workers by creating an instant
connection to backend data using
familiar applications such as microsoft
excel sharepoint etc for analysis visual
representation and collaboration
the next is
sql server reporting services which is
used to generate reports
now ssrs is a framework of reporting
mechanisms such as the report builder
report designer report manager and
report server that work together through
a web interface to enable the
development of concise interactive
reporting solutions in print or web
format
report builder and report designer are
two ssrs components for generating
reports
report builder is a simple solution for
the information worker or business user
to create quick reports without the need
to understand the core structure of the
data
the report designer is a tool for
developers because it adds complexity to
custom reports development and you
create data models in it
using this tool requires an
understanding of the business
intelligence development studio shell in
visual studio
and the underlying structure of the data
so you have to be aware of it thoroughly
according to microsoft the report server
is the core process engine in ssrs that
manages the processing
and delivery of reports using processors
the report manager is an administrative
tool that controls reporting services
through a web interface
now let's talk about another important
component which is sql server
integration services ssis which is being
used to perform atl operations extract
transform load
now ssis is the data warehousing arm of
the sql server
equipped with superior extract transform
and load capabilities etl
it provides the vehicle for moving data
from different data sources to another
and changing the data if necessary the
three components in the ssis platform
for starting the data integration
process
are the import and export wizard ssis
designer and ssis api programming
the import and export wizard simply
transfer data from source to destination
but does not include data transformation
capabilities it's the ssis designer is
an integrated component of the business
intelligence
development studio used for the
development and maintenance of
integration service packages
ssis api programming module allows you
to code ssis packages using any number
of programming languages so there are a
lot of features which are available to
you in order to
manage your data create your data
pipeline structure it
build visualization reports
perform etl operations etc so it's an
entire solution enterprise solution
now let's see what are the different
kind of sql server editions microsoft
provides five additions with various
tools and services and pricing options
as per the needs
so enough two editions of sql server
which are free of charge are sql server
developer and sql server express
now the developer sql server edition
works and function exactly like an
enterprise sql edition the only
difference is the license is used for
testing and development purpose only
this addition is generally used by
developers to build and test
applications on top of the sql server
but they can't take it to the production
sql server express edition now is the
free entry level database version and is
ideal for learning and building desktop
and small server data driven
applications but not meant for any
serious computation
while also having incredibly limited
features
now the other additions are used for
commercial purposes
sql server web edition
it is a low total cost of ownership
option for web hosts and web value ad
providers to provide scalability
affordability and manageability
capabilities for small to large scale
web properties
as the sql server enterprise edition
delivers comprehensive high-end data
center capabilities with blazing fast
performance unlimited virtualization and
end-to-end business intelligence
enabling
high service levels for mission critical
workloads and end user access to data
insights
this version has all the features
required for big data
now sql server standard edition this
delivers basic data management and
business intelligent database for
departments and small organizations to
run their applications and support
common development tools for on premise
and cloud enabling effective data
management with minimal i.t resources
now let's look at some advantages of sql
server instances
its installation is of different
versions on one machine you can maintain
different installations the maintenance
of production development and test
environments can be done separately
you can maintain a standby server
so installation is streamlined it can be
installed via setup wizard and the
prerequisites
updates are detected and downloaded by
the installer automatically
the complexity of the installing the
software is minimized significantly
because of automatic installation of
updates
other components such as analytical and
database services can be installed
separately afterwards
automatic updation also reduces
maintenance costs quite significantly
sql server 2008 uses policy management
to detect security policies that are not
compliant so this feature allows only
authorized personal access to the
database security audits and events can
be written automatically to log files
ms sql server has built-in transparent
data compression feature also along with
encryption users don't need to modify
programs in order to encrypt the data
the ms sql server has access controlled
coupled with efficient permission
management tools
further it offers an enhanced
performance when it comes to data
collection
okay and
coming to the cost reduction so it has
lower cost of ownership sql server
includes effective data management and
data mining tools along with disk
partitioning your server's optimum
maintenance can be ensured by following
effective data management practices
these practices
also help you ensure the availability
and recoverability of data choose from
over 300 in-demand skills and get access
to 1 000 plus hours of video content for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now let's move on to
creating
a
database in sql server
so i have installed the default sql
express on my machine
and now i'm gonna
create a database called sql tutorial
so let's create a database called sql
underscore
tutorial
okay
now i will write certain queries on top
of it
first i'll create a table
customers let's create a table customers
which has columns customer id which is
its primary key
the name
which has where care customer id is in
age
which is an integer gender male female
will
notified with one character address
which is generally a large num string
value so we'll keeping it back at 20
item which is varchar 15 and price okay
so let's
create this table
okay so now if you see this table has
been created dbo dot customers now all
the relevant columns which i created
here has been present
now
i have
prepared a script to insert
some sample values
so that
we can
query this so i have inserted around
about 20
values
so let's just check
whether my data is present i'll do a
select star
from my customer table and you can see
now the 20 rows with the customer id
customer name
age gender
address
the item which the customer has
purchased and the price at which he has
purchased
now
let me show some variations of the
queries which we can perform
now select star means you have selected
all the columns
i only want to select some
selective columns like customer name and
gender
so i can also do that you just need to
give the name of the
customer and the gender column
next query
i want to check
what is the distinct values of the
gender in my customer table
so i will only get two values which is
male and female so there is no other
value apart from m and f
in my customer table
next i have a query where i want to find
which all are the customers who have
purchased an item who all are the
customers who have purchased an item
which is having price greater than 250
rupees
okay great so out of 20 only 12 other
customers who have purchased a price
item which is greater than 250 and you
can see
all the items which are listed over here
are greater than 250.
next
okay i want the customers who are living
in new york
okay
fine i just have to change the where
clause where instead of the price i am
now looking at the address which is in
new york
now it is also possible that you can
apply
another filter okay
people living in new york but age is
greater than 28
perfect i only have two customers who
are
living in new york
but
having age greater than 28
or
i want
the female customers who are purchasing
items greater than 380 rupees okay only
one out of 20
okay elena
now
we saw examples of and condition
there is also possibility that okay you
want female customers or customers who
are greater than age 30 so you will get
both the records age greater than 30 or
female customers both the records will
come
or
customers who are in chicago or
purchasing
items greater than 420. so these are the
examples of or conditions
now let's take another example of not
now i want that the customers who are
not
purchasing price less than 650 the
reverse right greater than 650 so i'll
get this answer
or
i want the customers who are not living
in new york apart from new york
any other address so all these customers
are there okay
so now these are the examples which i
showed you are the examples where you
can play around you can filter data
applying the where clause
now let's take another example of
aggregated functions in sql
now amongst the list of customers the
data set of customers which i have i
want to know what is the minimum age of
my customer well minimum age is 18 years
so one the minimum age amongst the all
the customers is 18
and the maximum is
i can just change it to max
is 61. so the age range of my customers
who are purchasing are from 18 to 61.
okay now another example hypothetical
example
i want the average age of my customers
where customer id is greater than 105
okay so if you see
select star
where customer id is greater than 105 i
have 15 customers and amongst these
my average age
of my customers is 35.
similarly instead of average i can take
the sum total of the
age
above 105 which is 539 sum total okay
now
i'll show you an example of like
i want the name i want the customers
list where addresses
which consist of e letter e in their
address it anywhere in the string
beginning in the middle because i have
like
is a keyword like percentage first e
percentage means e can come in any part
of the string
okay
and if i just change this example
i remove the percentage from here it
means
that i want the customers whose
addresses end with e so only pune will
come into the picture okay
so
so this is the difference
now coming select star from customers
where age which between 20 and 30 so i
want all the customers which have belong
to age between age 20 and 30 inclusive
so 20 and 30 both are inclusive so it
means the customers which with age 20
and all 30 will also come in this result
set
next example i want the count of total
customers in my
uh data set which is 20 i inserted 20 so
i know now i have 20
i want the count of male customers
oh out of 20 19 are male okay great
and if i
group by now let's see an example of
group by
so i want
the count of customers grouped by
address so how many are living in boston
how many in chicago detroit miami new
york and pune so i have a customer wise
total count total
bases the address group by okay so it's
a very important concept you can group
by any column and then you can do a
measure count account or sum an average
you can do any aggregated calculation
basis the other columns which are not in
the group by
unlike another example i want an average
age
per address so in boston the average age
of my customer is 34 who are purchasing
items chicago 35 pune 43. so like that
you can do some analysis this is all
data analytics
now let's see another example
i want to i want to filter data now
after doing a group by it's not so
please note this is different from where
clause in where clause means filtering
data before grouping
having clauses used once you want to
filter data after grouping
so you are doing group by address count
of customers and then only those cities
should come where count is greater than
two okay
so the customers
the only those addresses are listed
where customers count is greater than
two okay
now this is an example of
inner queries
you want
group by customer name and age
only those customers having age greater
than the average age of overall okay so
my average age
if i say my average age
from customers is 36
so overall all the customers which are
more than 36 should come over here
listed over here and that's what has
happened okay
now
let's talk about order by it's like
sorting
you want to order by address so it has
ordered by by default b c d m n p which
is
ascending
and if you
apply
keyword descending
so it will do the reverse way
similarly i can order by age
which is descending higher stage first
lowest below
or
you can do order by multiple columns
where
order by address descending and then
same address within the same address the
customers should be ascending so
addresses are descending but within the
address the customer names are sorted in
ascending fashion a first bcd like that
now there is an inbuilt function in sql
server reverse if you see this has
reversed the name
of the customers it's in reverse fashion
okay
the characters are reversed
another example is
where you are now this is not on the
table this is just a sample query where
you are replacing vegetable with fruit
so orange is a fruit so you have
replaced vegetable with the fruit it is
just uh you don't need a table you can
just also write such queries where you
don't need a table
okay
then there is a function called ltrim
which is which will remove all the
blanks
from the
left hand side
r trim which will remove the blanks from
the right hand side
okay let me read an r trim
it will remove the
blanks from the right hand side and then
there is trim function which will remove
from both the sides
left and right
now let's take an example of update
command i want to update the name of my
customer whose customer id is 103.
first
let's
check what's the name
the customer name right now is ripple i
want to change it to
smith
and if i read query it is changed to
smith okay so this is an example of
update
now if i want to delete let me check who
is at 101 i want to delete customer101
joseph i will delete it
and now if i want to check okay there is
no customer at one zero one
okay now let's take one other example
this is like another example of inbuilt
function as sky it will give you the
ascii code of the character
ascii a
sky 4 etc etc right
so there is n number of
possibilities there is n number of
queries which you can write but
this is just a glimpse and basic
understanding of for you to get started
with sql queries on sql server
i hope you all had a great learning
session and i hope to meet you in my
next session thank you
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here